hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to thread halls now you may
be asking yourself markiplier
you handsome devil bastard you haven't
you already beaten this game before yes
I did on the first oculus rift but they
recently updated the game and
re-released it for the second dev kit of
the oculus rift and this is the only
game that has actually made me cry from
how scary it was I'm not exaggerating
you can find a link to the video in the
description below if you haven't seen it
already and I figured that you guys
would want me to see me suggest subject
myself to this sort of Terror again so
here we go because I'm like that and I'm
a glutton for punishment and I never
know when to stop oh ye familiar place
you now if you remember about this game
at all which you may or may not it's a
randomly generated dungeon crawling type
game with all sorts of devilish Cooley's
within its halls and I have no idea how
to beat it because it's been a long time
in Iconix spell the memories from my
brain I don't know if they added
anything new to the game but I do know
they plan to release this as a full game
in the future I do not like you
god I don't remember a damn the wall
yeah I remember that some of these doors
take longer than other doors so bear
with me is absolutely nothing mix-ups on
me Oh God I remember you how do I close
the damn door go now thank you
I'm okay actually oh good the Freak was
that you want to run that by me again
here's the oil engine oh god I forgot oh
yes that
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
shut up with your stupid-ass rambling I
hate you so much game oh I hate you so
much
shut up that's nothing it's all lies
this whole game is filled with lies oh
god I forgot how much I absolutely hate
how about no my skeletony friend god
dammit
there's a reason there is a goddamn
reason why this game haunts me to this
day especially for the goddamn occure
IFFT and it is better and that it's more
immersive now it's got head tracking all
that good stuff and I can actually peek
around corners which is nice don't know
if that's actually gonna help me or if
I'm just deluding myself I gotta take
this nice and slow
we started off a little extreme those
are just barrels no need to be scared
what is that the torch I know nothing
and a dude chilling on the cage I need
to find a lot more oil than that if I'm
gonna survive this game god damn it
screw you that happened to me before
I remember that given that I've already
beaten this game I reserve the right to
rage quit at any moment
okay I was wondering it was quiet I was
just waiting for the orchestra to pick
it back up can I get that out of my face
I'm looking for a chest with some oil
hi I heard you don't you frickin there I
see oh there's a lot of you why are
there so many of you hi friend
you're looking good I'm just gonna oh
you're so friendly and happy I'm out of
here
dammit ok where am I going I went into a
dead-end I should have known that okay
it's gonna take it nice and calm we
really did kick it off on a high note if
it was my personal choice I would
continue the low low soothing baritone
notes but Dad I don't think this game is
gonna give me a choice
the whispering is picking up intensity
okay
what is that no no no what is that
what oh it's a gargoyle okay follow us
something else
so I'm Selma I actually needed to be
worried about just kidding I'm worried
about everything shut up with your
boobie shop
no you do not oh you do not do that to
me
oh okay where am I going to something a
verb a why is it black why do you get
black over there why'd it get black when
I turn my head oh I'm so dead I'm so
dead oh I'm good I said I'm dead what is
that what is it oh god it's so weird cuz
I can actually peer around corners and
this is not fun
hi dude how's it going look good god
damn I'm gonna run out oil aren't I what
is that who's there I don't know if I
even need that but I think I do I feel
like I do in my bones
I shouldn't say my bones because I'll
end up like one with the skeleton
friends oh thank you Boyle no okay I'm
good thanks though way to did it I am in
a dead end
oh god damn I'm such an idiot I'm never
gonna make it out of here I'm never
gonna make it out of here okay something
was I never did figure out what was
actually a thing what was just things
with here we go Todd it just gets
periods of quietness I really don't
enjoy it
oil no all right Oh oil well more oil
over there okay good just decide to hop
over that for a shortcut some so extreme
that I don't know what that is is that
500 notes wait a minute did I read these
notes before much longer do I have to
wait I don't know until something
happens hopefully not long I really
imagined okay moving forward holding
brave here we go into the darkness the
unknown chest yes you got for me
oil yes shut up you're nothing I know
you're nothing I'm okay I'm okay
what is that let something down there
what is that what are you what are you
oh your door god damn it screw you yeah
let me check here first I'll come back
the other way what this stores already
open is that a good sign or a bad sign
okay got that okay we're good still good
still good I can make it out of here I
can do this I can beat it actually beat
this that's probably not a good thing
whoosh lots of oil in here huh it's good
I would like to read the notes but ok
they are watching us who is okay I
caught mo talking when she thought I
slept she won't tell me soon I thought I
saw how and it didn't see me the judge
is kind to us a sentinel call me today I
could escape but it hurt here the blood
behind the walls is that the blood I
don't think that's the blood BRE the
hell am I going Oh goddamn okay okay
okay where do I go going ok let's try
going this way not that way
[Music]
[Music]
okay cargo is in here a couple gargles
that's fine gargoyles are good they're
fine they can do whatever they want okay
all right then let's go where'd the
other one go what there we go no
seriously where did the other one go
there's something moving over there
there's some legitimately Roman oh oh oh
sorry oh okay
no no Oh Mike Hey
going in a big-ass circle
big giant cycle cycle a cycle why do we
even care about the coins what would I
even care at this point no we found
Greg's remains today the judge had no
mercy on him you damn right Greg with
the douche and he got what was coming to
him pending this okay that's the door I
don't know pen I wanna know what that
thing that was moving behind that other
thing was that be nice oh hey this game
so goddamn much
come on why is that unlocked that's why
that's nothing
well that sounds like whoa whoa oh my
god that was actually something Oh time
you don't do that to me
god you're such a douche okay went that
way I think is that what's that are they
all actually something oh there's a long
hallway I don't like a long hallway
where do they go who's the exit thought
of tele Oh God
oh my gosh follow us right by the exit
the whole time I probably ran away in a
panic from wherever that lady was I know
the lady no the lady not here excuse me
Oh what is that there's a candelabra
what is that
bones more bones oh my goodness oh my
goodness oh lady hi lady okay lady
um um is there an exit in there is there
an exit in there I'm gonna say no and
leave I did not know that every single
goddamn sound in this game was actually
a thing that is not cool it was not cool
did I go this way I think I did I did
okay I did
don't be creaking oh okay there's one
more way I haven't gone yet I think okay
I can make it
everything's cool everything is awesome
okay there we go I haven't been using
them every time might have been a better
better better bit of a panic
Oh God if any of you have an oculus rift
even access to the first version God and
you love the horror games play this one
I'm okay whoa what was that oh come on
where's the exit then everywhere oh wait
there's one room down off to the side
over there that I didn't see okay that's
where I'll go next I got this I got this
I got it down this way right okay I'm
good
hi I didn't go in there because of you
that's right whoa no you don't oh it's
not over here that's right you're not
here I don't care about you I do not
care about you down this way to the
right yeah
okay exit exit that yes yes I beat it
again Oh Oh God if you got an oculus
rift you have to check that out I don't
care what you think about the game you
need to check this one out
it is yeah air flying in every way it's
something about not knowing what's
around every corner and the sense of
mystery and once I found out that
everything was actually I'm just messing
with me that that changed something so
seriously play this game I've been
trying to get vanished to work for the
oculus rift but I can't get it to work
with this dev kit and I gave away my
first version so I'm gonna try to get
get ahold of the dev kit number one
because in the second Emma kit with had
tracking in and a lot of games are
having trouble being compatible with it
but anyway hope you guys enjoyed this
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotations more videos that I've
done check the description for the first
time I play this game and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]